[Music] pass across from Kane the
brink and escapes right in front he's
got de brinka will get this Puck it's deflected
he had the slow down a second got inside and
goes top shelf what a shot by Alex De brinken
over Casey to Smith de brinken did a nice job
of dragging that skate and kept it on the ice
the Hawks now have scored Power Play Goals in
back-to-back games that's only the second
time off season that's happening here's to
brinkin at three games in a row Alex to
brinkin Roofing a wrer from Point Blank
Range after a great pass Patrick Kane
makes a heck of a pass here watch this
pass and then the quick shot backhand forehand
top shelf that's a world class play the pass but
it was a world class shift for Patrick Kane
rebound back back to Kane he goes across the
break it what a a turnaround pass what a
feed by Patrick Kane he gave to breaking a
tap in that was spectacular watch this pass
from Patrick Kane this is ridiculous watch
him get it here little spin around how do you
like it on the table Kane knows exactly where
to Brink it is no chance for barlam off that
is a picture perfect pass from Kane and back
com to bring it to Kane to Brak it to the
net there's the pass bouncing Bucky guard a
give go Kane and the and combine again for an
OT gwg watch the hands from Alex the brinken
he bats it once he bats it again about a foot
and a half off the ice and that's how he beats
cor pasalo those are some nasty hands right
there and the cat scores his eighth of the
year now to break it threw it back in front
here's the back sh they score Patrick Kane
a takeaway by to Brink a set up for Kane and
bang beautiful pass by Alex to Brink it who
just jumped on the ice the shoot in by Murphy
and then the beautiful pass there from the cat
and Patrick Kane goes top shov with the back
[Applause] hand the bring it to Kane for the
BR he's scor on a play to bring it to Kane to the
cat bang OT gwg and the Hawks win for the first
time in time this is the definition of a given
go you give it to Kane you go to the middle and
a great redirection Patrick Kane that was a hot
pass he knew that the brink it would be in front
with the redirection and that was perfectly placed
great way to the middle and then a stick left by
Kane he's Tri and and they score the kanes had
clean possession should have been an easy clear
Patrick Kane with a stick Li and Alex to break in
the Finish Kane moves it over to the cat Hax had
nothing going on on that power play and then
Kane with a good quick stick lift not around
the hands right on the shaft of the stick Kane
to the other end looking for help from him to
break it Kane is sp he's SC oh roll the highlight
film Patrick Kane with a spectacular savwa Fair
spinorama with that backand all in one motion
the sarian spinorama and as he's finishing the
spin he puts a little spin on the puck that
backand just inside the blocker between the
body of Rhymer and the unbelievable Patrick Kane
has given this team some life come up with a set
play here so here with the delayed penalty Kane
on the stick SS into crosses scor this is just
all skill and a dynamic duo of De Brink and Kane
come out the ice pick it up and then de Brink is
so good at getting himself available and Kane
on the backand right wing speed hey moving in
Slams on the brakes gives to Guston down low
in front to Brink it tapping he scores Alex
De Brink it and they're on the board and in the
game oh beautiful Tic Tac Toe passing play from
Kane to De Brink it great chance off the rush the
playmaking by Patrick Kane it's a thing of beauty